hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to teenage
mutant fucking Ninja Turtle this is the
shit while we were growing up Ninja
Turtles were everywhere comic books TV
shows breakfast cereals they even had a
PI named after him
it tasted like splooge but we didn't
care as long as I had the Ninja Turtles
on it we were happy
so when we heard they were actually
making a live-action movie based on this
phenomenon we proudly pissed our pants
with joy we shit ourselves with
excitement
we vomited up vast amounts of excrement
shit on it rolled around in it put it
back in our mouths and proceeded to
vomit it up again in roaring
anticipation ok maybe only I did that
but still bottom line we were hyped as
hell these movies kicked ass back then
and I'm sure they're going to kick ass
now what just to say I haven't actually
seen these movies in years but that's
why it's a special treat I'm going to
sit down and review the movies with you
as you're watching it with me so grab
your vintage Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
box of cookies and enjoy the show
just watch the movie all right
New York so far so good actually I like
this opening because it doesn't even
look like a ninja turtles movie this
could be the opening to shaft watch
who's a black private dick
sex machine don't chicks shocked
you see April O'Neil Channel 3 whoa
who is that April O'Neil no no no no no
no no listen lady I'm sure you're a fine
actress and everything but uh you're not
a brony oh no no it's how do you see
here is April O'Neil yellow jumpsuit
nice legs damn she's fine
so come on where's the real a brony oh
come on cover-up just what is going on
out there April okay all right no no
that's cool that's cool you know no prob
I mean at least we still get to see her
in the yellow jumpsuit right oh come on
that's not a jumpsuit that's a raincoat
there is a difference there is I don't
look you're watching I'll show you the
difference here watch clothes
jeongsu raincoat Junsu Renko jumpsuit
Rico Johnson Rico Johnson oh my god says
the turtles had better be a hell of a
lot better right Jess excuse me one
moment
oh my god look at those costumes but
those are incredible the fans exactly
will radioactive ninjitsu reptiles in
their late teens would look like I mean
if they're unbelievable I mean if
they're phenomenon me oh my god I
apologize for that
but even you had to admit those costumes
are pretty incredible the guy who put
these all together with Jim Henson the
Muppet guy and do you know how much
those puppeteers have to squat in order
to get their hands up those asses it's
not even worth thinking about if this
movie was done today chances are they
probably turned them all into
computer-generated images publish it
they set out to rescue April from the
evil Foot Clan who want to destroy her
because she's giving evil pajama-wearing
psycho-pass a bad name oh no you did it
all right April's gonna kick some ass
as you probably guessed the turtle save
April and take her back to their home in
the sewers there she meets the Ninja
Turtles mentor a giant rat named
splinter and I have to admit saying this
all out loud it's making me realize just
how friggin weird this movie is when did
it go up with this stuff
so splinter explains to April the origin
where they came from you see years ago
splinter was just an ordinary pet rat in
Japan after his master is murdered
splinter somehow makes it to New York
and comes across a canister of booze and
four baby turtles within a day both the
turtles and splinter grow in size and
even begin to form words beat that exact
it could happen
splinter decides to name them after the
famous Renaissance painters because
giant mutated turtles seem to scream of
the Renaissance period it made sense
back then wondering how much acid she
drop April decides to help them defeat
the foot and bring order to the city and
on their way there helped by a vigilante
known as Casey Jones who's pretty cool
despite the fact they looks like Jason's
homosexual Canadian brother mmm now the
leader of the Foot Clan is an evil
kitchen utensil known as the shredder
which everyone says is a giant Darth
Vader ripoff but I don't see the
resemblance Oh Bob okay it's a ripoff
but you gotta give this guy credit he
has a diabolical scheme too actually
what was the plan again honey I'm sorry
uh I don't care how menacing or powerful
you are uh there's no way you can make
punishing turtle sound threatening I'm
sorry it's just not evenly possible but
you see he's using kids and teenagers to
fight his battles if you went up to a
hitman and said you wanted them to hunt
down some turtles they'd probably laugh
in your face however if you get a bunch
of stupid kids don't them off their
asses get dressed up in shiny metal
recruit them to be ninjas and then ask
them to hunt down some turtles dude
sign me up
my only problem with this plan is the
costumes they're assigned I mean I know
they're supposed to be ninjas and
everything but those costumes are so
tight I don't even think they can talk
one of the things I love about this
movies the Turtles disguises which is
pretty much just a trench coat and a
fedora and how can nobody recognize them
in that I mean how stupid do people have
to be to not recognize a big turtle in a
trench coat look like sort of a big
title in a trench coat the movie comes
to a thrilling climax at the top of a
tall building where the shredder
challenges our heroes to a man on turtle
brawl and of course being the Ninja
Turtles they get their green asses
handed to them what point did we lose
control here but all that changes when
splinter comes into the picture its
sensei versus sensei shyam brat versus
giant cheese grater the Battle of all
battles begins here it goes
this has got to be good
here it comes
bullshit
what kind of battle is that he sticks
out by like a cartoon character and he
treads what am i bought all I guess is
the next film had better be a lot better
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles to a secret
of the use and what exactly is the
secret of the use it was made in a
laboratory and that's about it there's
not really any surprises on top of that
kind of a big letdown but the turtles
are back and this time around they're
well more kid-friendly I guess after all
the parents complained about the
violence and swearing in the first film
you know everything that made it good
the second film tones down the action at
the bad language so instead of using
their weapons to fight people they use
stuff like cold food belts and yo-yos
you know stuff you find lying around the
house so now all your kids will know how
to train ordinary household appliances
into blunt badass weapons
thank you parents of America idiots and
as for the bad language I don't know I
don't remember too much swearing in the
first film ninja kick the damn rabbit
damn okay okay so every kid was wearing
like a bastard after they saw this movie
but granted it's a lot better than their
original cut oh yeah man I don't think
it's around a quarter without me what my
fuck that man what my dad never let
spike lee director children's movie can
you believe this guy's so the story
centers around the return of the
sinister shredder after doing a short
ripoff of Tim Burton's Batman he gets
back into action by plotting his revenge
against those pop-culture spewing
reptiles he steals a canister of ooze
from that guy in Titanic and decides to
make his own Evil Mutants within seconds
two innocent harmless animals are
transformed into the sinister duo of
bebop and rocksteady
Hong Kong river yeah like I said bebop
and Rocksteady now the one scene
everyone remembers is the fight scene
that takes place in the whitest of all
ramp clubs led by the whitest of all
rappers you guessed it Vanilla Ice
gee it looks like they're pretty freaked
out about all those monsters breaking
into their club wait a minute
I think the ice is feeling something
I think he's conjuring up a rap a sort
of ninja rap if you will yo if the green
is look at that a totally unrehearsed
yet somehow totally choreographed rap
scene entirely made up on the fly
what Talent I gotta tell you this guy is
going places like the unemployment line
so the film climaxes as the shredder
drinks what's left of the mutated booze
and turns into a mutant himself Jesus
Christ look at that that is a badass
villain it's a super shredder all right
this is gonna make up for the shitty
climax in the last movie for mutant
turtles versus one giant mutant shredder
this is gonna be good
Wow are you telling me that a regular
shredder can survive a seven-story fall
and a dump truck crushing him and yet a
super shredder can't survive a bunch of
wood falling on him bullshit bullshit
bullshit you know I'm starting to
realize that uh these movies aren't
quite the masterpieces I remember them
to be I mean they're weird as hell they
don't make any sense and they keep
pissing me off with their anti climaxes
but I shouldn't give up hope after all
there is still one last movie left
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 3 and
seeing how now they've had two movies to
experiment with and find out what works
and what doesn't I think we can safely
assume that this is going to be the best
of the bunch so sit back and let's enjoy
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 3
oh this is the worst thing that no one
should ever have to see it's awful it's
it's terrible it it's it's so bad I am
forced to make up a word to describe how
bad it is this movie is is horrible
Bacchus it's the most horrible fucus
movie I've ever seen in my entire life
okay like I said these movies aren't the
masterpieces we remember them to be but
it's best not to look at them as movies
but more as a homework assignment make a
movie about four mutated Turtles in
their late teens who are named after
Renaissance painters led around by a
giant rat no ninjutsu eat pizza dress up
like flashers fight a guy who's named
after a cheese grater and make it
plausible and you know what with the
exception of the last movie I probably
get this project than a - but still an a
I'm a Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't have to